captain yeah right uh what do you want
mangus he's good he's good he's good i'm
good cool i'm great as a matter of fact
that was actually a great result um
yeah considering the position i had that
was pretty pretty that was the most i
could hope for obviously and neither of
them are on the street now okay
he's thinking good
i'm gonna play any salani position i've
lost the tempo but he
got his queen on c7 which i think is
not that useful
oh tricky tricky
it's 94 work
it may actually work
it's pretty sick
i think yeah
think more dial
love to see it
okay i'm gonna get some d5 going
quincy forest 95.
does this really work
he's got h6 as well
seriously
this [ __ ] doesn't even work
okay now it works
this time i have a better ending
take it
actually saw that but i hoped he
wouldn't spot it
okay
it's gonna
go down to
the famous wire
did i plunder this
okay where do i have to go okay i have
to go back
now i can maybe still win
queen g2
yes now we win
now we win
yes okay good stuff good stuff
try and get back to the streak
as soon as i can